Scarlett thank you the associated press  is confirming that pop superstar prince  has died at his home in suburban  Minneapolis at the age of 57 we'd  received word about half an hour ago  that there was a fatality at his home in  suburban Minneapolis also his Studios  they're known as Paisley Park studios  there was a report about a week or so  ago that princess private jet had been  diverted because he had gotten sick on  the plane there were reports that he had  flu-like symptoms but again The  Associated Press is reporting that a  publicist says that pop music superstar  prince has died at his home in suburban  Minneapolis at the age of 57 we'll  continue to follow this breaking news  and bring you more details as soon as we  get them back